Guys, it is time for
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
Here we go.
-♪ Hashtags ♪
♪♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
-Now, we do this thing every
week where I send out a hashtag
and I ask you guys to respond
to that topic.
This week,
in honor of tonight's guest's
Molly Shannon's show
"The Other Two"
about a dysfunctional
brother and sister,
I sent out the hashtag
#MySiblingsWeird.
And I asked you to tweet out
your funniest
weird sibling stories.
Within minutes, it was
a trending topic in the U.S.,
so thank you for playing along.
And now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
#MySiblingsWeird tweets
from you guys.
Here we go. The first one
is from @Caroline--
Oh, there's some weird ones.
-Yeah.
-This first one's from
@CarolineJosephs. She says...
[ Hisses ]
-Ssss!
-This one's from @DJTheOldMan.
-Ooh.
-They say...
[ Applause ]
-Swallow 'em?
I don't know. It is weird.
This one's from @Stillwatergirl.
No sparkling. Thank you.
-Oh, yeah.
-I'm -- I'm Stillwater Girl.
-Yeah.
-Or maybe she's still
Water Girl.
It's like, "Hey, remember years
ago you were Water Girl?"
"No, I'm still Water Girl."
-It's fine.
-Or like
still water runs deep.
-Oh, that's true.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Deep Girl.
-Or Stillwater the band from...
-"Almost Famous."
-Yeah.
She's a big fan of the movies.
-Love it.
-She says...
[ Laughter ]
That's fun, man.
-Come on.
-"Yeah. You haven't met Norman?
Oh, he's so cool."
-He told that to his therapist.
-This one's from
@LiterallyHatGuy. He says...
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @Robnhood6.
They say...
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-God bless, right? God bless.
-Yeah.
-This one's from @gumgumerson.
-Oh. Great.
-He says...
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
This one's from @Sloan-B-07.
They say...
[ Laughter ]
-Don't! Don't you breathe!
-Rules are rules! Yeah.
This one's from @valerielyn77.
She says...
[ Audience groans ]
-Ooh. Ohh.
-Come on.
-[Chuckling] Ohh, no.
-This last one's
from @jennifurray. She says...
-There you have it, everybody.
Those are "Tonight Show"
Hashtags.
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.